so the ultimate freaky wakeup is in
space and it's just kind of eerie kind
of lighting and people are floating
around nothing my god what has happened
and there oh yeah that's right I'm in
space I'm Mike Massimino and this is how
sleep is different in space
I was an astronaut a NASA astronaut for
18 years
I flew in space two times two missions
on the space shuttle both of those
missions were missions to the Hubble
Space Telescope where I was a space
Walker so I got the spacewalk four times
in my career at NASA I think the most
extraordinary thing you can do in life
is to get outside of the spaceship and
spacewalk I really felt like I was a
real spaceman when I was out there you
can look in any direction you're not
just constrained by the window so you
see this gigantic wall taking up your
field of view and it's it's magnificent
sleep is very important for your health
and there's no doubt about it
people generally I think don't get
enough sleep that's what we hear and I
think that that's true and even in my
case here on earth I think at first it's
a bit harder to sleep in space because
you're trying to get used to it but for
me once I got used to it after a couple
days it was probably the best sleeping
I've ever had
on earth in your bedroom you most likely
sleep in a bed with the pillow behind
your head and warm covers on and maybe
the rooms a little cooler usually it's a
good idea for it to be dark maybe a
glass of water by the bed in case you
get thirsty access to the restroom as
you get older that's more and more
important that's a whole nother issue
you have it set up so you'd come for you
can get a good night's rest in space
it's different so on the Space Shuttle
we did not have a separate bedroom we
had a flight deck in a mid deck usually
the commander and the pilot slept on the
flight deck and the crew slept on the
mid deck and we would set up our
sleeping bags in different places so
then you rolled up the sleeping bag when
you were done sleeping in the morning
and enrolled it back out at night and
the shuttle there really isn't that much
privacy you do have some privacy when
you use the the hygiene compartment the
toilet and so on there's a curtain that
you can pull you can draw clothes and
have privacy so that's important and
everything else you do is kind of out
there with your friends so when you're
sleeping and when you're making a meal
or whatever it is you're probably have
someone else close by on space station
it's a bit different being in space for
only two weeks it's kind of like a
camping trip everyone's kind of in the
same room not a problem kind of fun but
if you're gonna be up different six
months like my friends up on the space
station you want a little more privacy
than that so they actually have a sleep
station a bedroom which is kind of like
a closet it's not really like a room is
more like a closet they'll have their
sleeping bag already mounted they don't
worry about rolling it up they can put
some of their clothing in there they can
put a computer in there their music
pictures of their family and you're in
there and you've got your privacy to
sleep comfortably so that's like your
own little bedroom in space on the space
station
so you sleep in a bed what you wear is
up to you you know I kind of like my
Snoopy pajamas well you might whatever
you feel comfortable and wearing or not
you can control the temperature so you
can put on the air-conditioning if you
need to if it's too hot or you can turn
the heat up I usually have a glass of
water next to my bed I don't use a sleep
mask or earplugs or anything like that
and generally works pretty well in space
on the space shuttle
we didn't have beds so I would have to
set up my sleeping bag our sleeping bag
is not like your regular sleeping bag
that you would have on a camping trip it
was more like a bed roll and you could
get in inside of it didn't have much of
a of a blanket was more like a canvas
sleeping bag it had a lot of straps and
hooks on it so you could hook it to
things so you know when to get on your
sleeping bag and float around the cabin
and wake up your friends and knock your
head so you would attach it with these
various hooks to different things that
you could hook it to so I set up my
sleeping bag on the ceiling so I could
sleep up there like I was a bat I
thought that was kind of cool and other
people slept different but it's like a
big slumber party and I would use those
hooks to set it up and then I would open
up the two pieces of canvas sort of and
get inside of it it's pretty comfortable
and then once you get inside you're kind
of in there and then you're floating
around with it I mean you're not
floating all over the place but you're
still floating within that sleeping bag
which is pretty cool and your arms
naturally in space will just rise up
like this like on earth you know we
don't necessarily walk around with our
hands up all the time and a little tough
on your shoulders to do that all day but
in space it's just they don't have any
weight to them so you even you actually
hands are kind of like just kind of
floats you see people like this when
I've heard this I thought this is a
little crazy but it works really well
it was so used to using a pillow on
earth the pillow is attached to the
sleeping bags kind of integrated right
with Velcro so you can take it off if
you need to and then there's a band more
or less attached to it that you wrap
around your head and it's very
comfortable I thought it would I thought
it sounded crazy but it works it's
usually pretty cold in the in the
spacecraft being a few degrees colder
than normal so I would wear gym shorts
and a t-shirt socks we'll have to keep
your head warm
and if you need a little extra you put
on sweatpants or sweatshirt so that was
my basic pajamas that's about it you
know you shut off the lights and you try
to make it quiet and cool and
comfortable and and try not to make too
much noise and have everyone try to get
a good night's rest
[Music]
on my first flight I wore an act watch I
was a Harvard University study from what
I remember somehow they collected data
with that thing to give us an idea of
our activity you know sleep cycles and
so on he had to keep a pretty good log
about when you were going to sleep and
what you were doing with that and I
think I was pretty conscientious about
that on my first flight my second flight
I wasn't as conscientious and I forgot
to wear the watch for a couple days and
they told me I didn't work for I forgot
to put it on a stand like okay we won't
be able to use your data but they do
they do track that or there are sleep
studies there really is no training to
actually sleep because the basic idea is
the same close your eyes and go to sleep
however you get a lot of information
about how you can do that more
comfortably in the different environment
of space so for example using earplugs I
don't normally use earplugs when I'm
trying to sleep on earth but in space
there's a somewhat of a constant whir of
machineries and sometimes a little
crackle of the comm system or something
like that so it could be a little noisy
so you use earplugs also you always kind
of keep a light on in case you wake up
you can get way tippy me get to the
restroom or do something so I wore sleep
masks in space against something I
normally don't wear when I'm on earth so
one of the best things about traveling
to space is that you don't have to pack
your own luggage
we have professionals to do that for you
because there's a lot of things you need
you don't want to forget anything I'm
sure I would have forgotten some
important things it's kind of a fun day
where you pick out what you're gonna
take for your personal hygiene items you
know do you want a an electric razor or
do you want to shave with shaving cream
with a regular razor and so those sleep
items are picked out in the same way
what kind of ear plugs you might want to
use what kind of sleep mask you might
want to use if you have a special one
from home that you want to bring you can
hand those in and they'll fly those and
then you keep them afterwards or they
can supply it for you and I did use a
little bit of mild sleep medication on
my first two nights in space I really
wanted to get my rest I was concerned
about not being able to fall asleep so I
did use a little bit of sleep medicine
for my first two nights and then I felt
like I didn't I
needed but it was really important to
get my rest if you want to bring your
teddy bear you can I did bring my Snoopy
with me I had a toy Snoopy that I
brought with me mission comes first and
if the teddy bear is gonna make you feel
more comfortable to get you better rest
I would say that's an essential item on
the Space Shuttle the way we woke up was
you would be woken up by wake-up music
they would rotate the wake-up music by
crew member based on what was going on
that day the family usually picks that
out your wife or your kids or someone
will pick that out for you and you can
try to guess whether or not it's it's
your song my first flight I heard Frank
Sinatra's fly me to the moon come on I
was convinced that was gonna be my song
but it wasn't I got the Mission
Impossible theme I think it was a lack
of confidence on a part of my family for
that one well in Space Station it's more
like an alarm that is set that'll go off
but the ground will make sure you're
you're awake and ready to go
[Music]
[Applause]
on earth and we have a 24 hour day we
have a morning and an evening I
generally get up early morning go to bed
not too late
try to do that space it's not gonna work
like that because you're travelling
around the planet at a very high speed
17,500 miles an hour which means you're
gonna make an orbit of our planet in an
hour and a half in about 90 minutes you
still maintain a 24 hour day you have
eight hours sleep period getting ready
for bed but call it pre sleep before
that a little bit of time after we call
post sleep or you're getting ready to
start your day and then you more or less
work in between that but as you're going
around the planet like this half the
time it's it's dark half the time it's
right every 45 minutes you go through
that transition you get 16 sunrises and
16 sunsets in a 24 hour period and so if
you are trying to plan your sleep
schedule around that you'd have to go to
sleep and wake up every 45 minutes it's
not going to work so you don't tell time
necessarily by whether it's it's light
light outside or dark outside
you go by the clock and in the shuttle
flights it was by mission elapsed time
that period while that's going on those
eight hours when you're sleeping you're
zipping around the planet still and it's
light outside and it's dark outside so
the darkness would probably be okay you
wouldn't necessarily wake up because of
the darkness but the bright sunlight it
is so bright the Sun is the brightest
light I've ever experienced it's almost
like a pure white lights that light gets
filtered a little bit through the window
and or if it gets filtered a lot by our
atmosphere so we don't get the same but
even on a very bright clear sunny day
it's nothing like being in space so we
have window shades so staying up late on
the Space Shuttle to look out the window
really wasn't an option because our
commander would block the windows with
these window shades so it would remain
dark and then the window shades would
come out during the during the day in
the morning now Space Station you have
your own little space of sleep in so you
close your little door and shut off the
light and it's dark and
there's no real need for window covers
there because they can come they can get
light and dark outside of your room and
you're not gonna notice on earth we have
our different senses to tell us where we
are visually we know we're upside down
right side up but more subtly maybe we
also have our vestibular system which
works on gravity our inner ear that
tells us if we're lying down and we're
standing straight up or we're upside
down or whatever it is we're moving
accelerating and so on in space your
vestibular system is telling your brain
nothing your eyes are saying moving
around but the inner ear was telling you
perfectly still and it can lead to
nausea which happened to me on my first
flight but your brain gets used to that
and after a couple days you can you can
be standing on the ceiling having a
conversation and you're fine that's
pretty cool and that's why you can sleep
on the ceiling you're floating up there
and close your eyes and your brains okay
with it
snoring is something I do on earth I
think it's unclear still of whether or
not you snore in space or as much I
always thought you didn't snore in space
that you know the net position that
we're on an earth and the way gravity
works in space you're you're kind of
floating there so I did not think that I
snored in space however I was told that
one of the later days during our flights
that I was actually snoring and one of
my crewmates had heard a trick to get
you to stop snoring was to grab the
person by the ankles I don't know if
this works on earth I don't know how she
found this out but apparently I was
snoring
and one of my crewmates got out of her
sleeping bag and grabbed me by the
ankles I don't know if that woke me up
or not but it stopped the snoring maybe
that's a hint something to remember if
you're ever in space in your crewmates
snoring
I have not had any nightmares related to
space I've dreamt a lot about space
though when you go to bed at the end of
a day in space I remember closing my
eyes and thinking about all the wondrous
things I had seen that my eyes had
really seen some cool stuff and I would
kind of dwell on that I have this you
know this recurring dream that I'm back
in space and we're going back to fix the
telescope one more time like there was
one more time ago and I'm up there with
my crewmates and we're doing different
things up there we were trying to fix oh
I do dream about going back to space a
lot sleep in space has kind of evolved
over the years right at first they
didn't sleep at all the first couple
missions were fairly short then they
started longer and longer and people
needed to sleep and then we made a big
leap with the space station in people
living there in meaning their own little
place to sleep and the next step might
be much longer missions where people are
going to Mars for six months or in the
future hopefully we're going much
further than that and you're still going
to need to sleep having a private area
might need to be a little bit larger
maybe your crew quarters needs to be a
little bit larger this idea for very
long for voyages of having like just
cryo sleep that you see in the movies
I'm not so sure about that you know I
don't know if I'd feel like I'm gonna go
sleep for five years but maybe that's
the way to do it I think we have time to
figure that out at this point I think
we've we've determined a couple things I
think having a private area where you
can feel comfortable like you are
comfortable in your bedroom when it's
time to go to bed I think we're pretty
good about knowing and it needs to be
quiet knowing about shifting you do need
your eight hours a day so I think all
these things that we learned have led us
to where we are now with space travel
and so I think we're all ready to go in
these longer voyages that will be
happening and sleep is gonna be a big
part of that I think to counteract that
we should find a better propulsion
system so you can get places a lot more
quickly then you don't have to worry
about that as much I think that
eventually will come as well but
sleeping is really important it's
important for us here on earth for our
health and well-being
and in space it's it's just as important
maybe even more so because you want to
be on the top of your game during a
mission
[Music]